should people be investing their money
right now if so where and what should
you invest in when the stock market is
down we connect with a financial expert
for some answers
with inflation in the price of gas and
consumer goods on the rise many folks
are feeling the burden on their wallet
looking for ways to supplement their
income and with money tight experts
advise folks to choose their investments
wisely if at all others argue it's best
to buy in at a discounted price no one
knows when the low is and when the high
is dr kaplan is the founder of i finance
one of the largest consumer lending
institutions in north america she says
with the overall market being down
long-term investors may want to consider
taking advantage of this opportunity a
dip in the market is your opportunity so
buy the debt and take advantage of the
prices are low right now if you're
taking a long-term perspective and again
it's a long-term perspective you need to
be patient historically the market goes
up over time so investing in the market
gives you a better chance for greater
earnings potential if you're young in
your twenties or thirties every dollar
you invest now could be worth fifteen to
twenty bucks by the time you retire if
you can afford to stock more money away
into the market for more than five or
ten years now is the time to do so and
it's always good she says to diversify
your portfolio with established
businesses investors may want to
consider other sectors that are
generally not hit so much by market
volatility and during an economic
slowdown things like consumer staples
utilities healthcare consider those